In this video i want to derive the mirror
equation. So what is a mirror equation? Some
of you might know what it is, and some may
be hearing it for the first time. Since it
has the word mirror in it, let’s first draw a mirror…
Should we draw a concave mirror or a convex one?
Well, the mirror equation works for both!
But let’s start with a concave mirror!
You are already familiar with all these symbols.
‘P’ is the pole, ‘C’ is centre of
curvature. It is the centre of a sphere of
which the reflecting surface is a part of.
The midpoint of C and P is the principal focus
F. And finally the line which joins all of
them is the principal axis.
Suppose that our object is kept behind C,
at a finite distance away from the mirror.
We draw our usual ray diagram to get the image
which is of course a real image.
So what is a mirror equation? Well let me
just write it down first… ‘One over f’
is equal to ‘one over u’ plus ‘one over v’.
What do these three letters symbolise?
They’re nothing but distances between points.
To understand better, let’s draw a tangent
at point P like this.
In this equation, ‘u’ is the distance
between the object and the mirror… So this
distance will be ‘u’. It is the distance
between points A and P. Remember, the distance
between two parallel lines will always be
the same! So this distance is nothing but
distance between points A and P.
’v’ is the distance between the image
and the mirror. Let’s name this point G.
So ‘v’ is nothing but the distance
between points G and P.
And ‘f’ is the focal length which is the
distance between the principal focus and the
pole.
This distance is equal to ‘f’. Note that all the distances
are measured from the
pole of the mirror and not some other point
on the mirror. So from the equation, you can
see that it gives us the RELATION between
the object’s distance from the mirror, image’s
distance from the mirror and the focal length.
What if instead of this, I had placed an object
somewhere else? It wouldn’t change our formula!
The equation does not depend on the object’s
position from the mirror. It is same for any
position of the object.
What if instead of concave mirror, we had
convex mirror? Again, it wouldn’t change
our formula! Yes , this formula is true for
ALL types of spherical mirrors: convex as
well as concave mirrors. Now the question
is how do we derive or prove this formula?
There are many ways to derive the equation
but we will look at the easiest one.
In order to derive this formula, we need to
know only one thing, and that is the concept
of SIMILAR TRIANGLES . You must have come
across similar triangles many times in our
maths class. So let’s review that first.
In simple language, triangles are said to
be similar if they have the SAME SHAPE . For
instance these two triangles are similar since
they have same shape. This triangle is just
a scaled down version of this.
These two are also similar triangles.
What’s so special about similar triangles?
When two triangles are similar then the ratios
of their corresponding sides are equal. For
instance, here ‘triangle ABC’ and ‘triangle
PQR’ are similar so, ‘AB over PQ’ is
equal to ‘BC over QR’ is equal to ‘AC
over PR’. And this fact is going to help
us derive the mirror equation!
The second thing about two similar triangles
is that all the corresponding angles have
the same measure. For example, here
‘angle A’ is equal to ‘angle P’, ‘angle B’
is equal to ‘angle Q’ and ‘angle C ’
is equal to ‘angle R’.
This also works in the reverse. That is, if
for any two triangles, if we prove that their
corresponding angles are equal, then they
are similar triangles. This is called triple
A test of similarity for proving two triangles similar.
Similarly, if the ratios of their corresponding
sides are equal then the triangles are similar.
Ok, let’s go back to our figure for the
mirror equation.
Now from the top of the object, let me draw
a line that meets the tangent at point B.
This line is parallel to the principal axis.
And from this point on the image, let me draw
a parallel line again to the tangent at point
D. Note that points B and D are not on the
mirror. They’re on this tangent which is
drawn at point P.
But actually both the points are very close
to each other the mirror in reality. This
is because we have seen in our previous video
that the aperture of the mirror that we are
considering is much smaller than the radius
of curvature. Because of the smaller aperture,
these distances are very small and so we can
assume these two points to be on the tangent.
So we can assume these two points to be one
point; and these two points to be one point.
Now consider these two triangles.
Are these two triangles similar?
Let me first just draw them separately here.
We see that ‘angle OAF’ is equal to angle
‘DPF’. Why? They both measure ninety degrees!
What about these two angles, ‘angle OFA’
and ‘angle DFP’? When two lines intersect,
the vertically opposite angles are always
equal. Hence these two angles are equal too!
What about the remaining angles? How do we
show that they are also equal? With very basic
logic, we know that if the two sets of corresponding
angles are equal then the third set has to
be equal . Finally we proved that triangles
OAF and DPF are similar by the double A or
triple A test of similarity.
Now because they’re similar, we can say
that ‘OA over DP’ is equal to ‘AF over
PF’ is equal to ‘OF over DF’. We are
not really interested in this ratio, so we
will just remove it from here.
Now, from this figure, can you tell me what
AF and PF represent? [pause]
PF is the FOCAL LENGTH ‘f’ but what about
AF? We know that AP is the object’s distance
from the mirror which is ‘u’. But AP is
equal to ‘AF plus FP’ and FP is the focal
length ‘f’! So AF is nothing but ‘u minus f'
And what are OA and DP? They are the heights
of the object and the image.
Let’s denote them with ‘h o’ and ‘h i’.
We are not done yet. This is not the formula
that we are looking for. Let this be equation
one. Now consider triangles IGF and BPF. These
two triangles are also similar again by the
triple A test. I will leave this for you to
verify.
The ratios of their corresponding sides are
equal.
I will remove this ratio, as it is not required.
IG and BP are nothing but the heights of the
image and the object. PF is the focal length
‘f’. So What's GF?
GP is equal to GF plus FP! We know that FP
is ‘f’. And what is GP? Yes, it is the
image’s distance from the mirror ‘v’.
Therefore GF is ‘v minus f’. Let this
be equation two.
Now let’s invert equation 2 to get the third
equation We are almost there now. So we have these
two equations now with us. They both have
the same term on one side of equal to sign,
so the other two sides will be equal.
Cross multiplying and solving further will finally
give us the required mirror formula.
Finally we have our mirror equation in front
of us! It was fun to derive it wasn’t it?
However this is not the only way to derive
the mirror equation.
Now if you remember, at the start of the video
I told you that this is a GENERAL EQUATION.
That is, this equation is valid for any position
of the object and for any spherical mirror
under consideration. But is it so? Ermm, in
order to use this equation, we must make sure
that some rules are followed. We will see
those rules in our next video.